Democratic presidential candidates are
making their final pitches to voters in
Nevada before tomorrows caucus they're
the newest statewide poll shows that
Bernie Sanders has a double-digit lead
over the rest of the field after he won
the New Hampshire primary last week ed
O'Keefe is covering the campaign in Las
Vegas good morning to you ad what are
the candidates saying well good morning
Gail ultimately Democrats are hoping to
defeat President Trump but for now
they're far more focused on beating up
each other take for example former Vice
President Joe Biden who's been
struggling in the polls and how he's
taking on the front-runner here senator
Sanders the fact is Bernie has had a
very different record than me for a long
time
former Vice President Joe Biden is
calling out senator Bernie Sanders has
passed opposition to legislation that
would have toughened gun laws he voted
against it five times in the house
representatives and in a state still
reeling from one of the worst mass
shootings in history Biden's campaign
also unveiled this ad I don't know that
you hold a gun manufacturer responsible
for what obviously a deranged person
Sanders has since reversed that position
and on Thursday was endorsed by the
cofounders of the gun control group
marched for our lives I'm proudly
endorsing Bernie Sanders for president
because he understands the actions that
must be taken to curb this issue also
new today another anti Sanders ad from a
moderate Democratic group raising
concerns about the health of the 78 year
old senator oh and he recently just had
a heart attack
Biden isn't the only candidate taking
swipes at Sanders we choose a candidate
who appeals to a small base like senator
Sanders it will be a fatal error
speaking of the former New York City
Mayor after a tough debate performance
this week Mike Bloomberg is scheduled to
be off the campaign trail in the coming
days preparing for next Tuesday's debate
but senator Elizabeth Warren once again
called on Bloomberg to release former
employees from non-disclosure agreements
if he's not willing to remove those bags
and let those women and maybe those men
talk then he is disqualified from being
president of United States Warren after
disappointing showings in Iowa and New
Hampshire is facing her own questions
about whether she can turn things around
Nevada I need to do what I've done
pretty much all my life and that is get
out there and fight for working families
that's me that's what I do
and then there's President Trump he's
also here in Las Vegas today for a
campaign rally of his own but Mayor
Bloomberg is spending some money here in
the city planning to put up billboards
like this one across the city especially
near the Convention Center where that
rally will be held perhaps a preview of
the kind of ways the former mayor plans
to spend his billions against the
president through the election in
November Tony did that say Donald Trump
eats burnt steak I don't know if I
understand because he likes his steak
overcooked the mayor is going to be
putting up insults like that on the
billboards across the city here I think
it's the kind of thing we'll be seeing a
lot more of through November we'll see
if that's disqualifying from voters what
it says